the latest big-screen Jumanji chapter
has some very good moments and just as
many disappointing ones here are three
of the most exciting things about
Jumanji the next level and three things
filmmakers could have skipped Kevin Hart
is obviously a funny guy
the man's a professional stand-up
comedian and he's made a lucrative
second career for himself as a movie
star Hart usually plays the same kind of
characters and they tend to act and
sound exactly like Hart does on stage in
Jumanji the next level Hart's screen
persona is wildly different because it
has to be since the avatar he plays
weapons keeper and zoologist Franklin
Mouse Finbar spends a lot of the film
inhabited by easygoing talkative retired
restaurant manager Milo played by Danny
Glover he has to act like Milo by way of
Mouse
it's a tricky balancing act and Hart
succeeds elevating his performance
beyond just an impression of the
soft-spoken Glover that would grow
tiring after 45 minutes of screen time
so Hart doesn't try to do the voice
exactly but rather nail the vibe of an
old man getting a huge kick out of
traipsing around a video game and
suddenly knowing dozens of animal fun
facts which he'll spout off at random
Hart brings the comic relief as is his
way but he also brings a sweetness and
softness that's otherwise lacking in a
movie full of action Dwayne Johnson can
do it all action comedy animated
musicals so what can't the rock do you
can't do Danny DeVito the plots of
Jumanji the next level calls for Johnson
to perform an extended imitation of the
distinctively voiced star of It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia if you're dumped a
bunch of woman's while Johnson tries
admirably he just can't pull it off and
the results are awkward sometimes he
just speaks loudly to evoke the spirit
of DeVito ignoring the New Jersey accent
entirely sometimes Johnson forgets to do
any sort of accent at all while his
comic timing is on point
Johnson's swinging a Miss that the
proper voice is hard to ignore
or terrible job will be talking about my
driver's test last month ok since
leaving behind her breakout role is
Amelia pond on Doctor Who in 2012 Karen
Gillan has certainly worked steadily
she's a supporting player in the vast
Marvel Cinematic Universe
almost unrecognisable as blue-skinned
alien nebula she also starred however
briefly in her own ABC sitcom selfie
portraying videogame heroine Ruby
Roundhouse in Jumanji welcome to the
jungle increased her profile and while
that was a big movie it's still amounted
to the supporting role but Gillan and
Ruby takes center stage in Jumanji the
next level
she's arguably the most prominent member
of the all-star cast leading the
expedition through the game world and
enjoying a couple of showcase action
sequences Gillan also provides the
emotional center of the movie with the
personality of Martha inside
she tells boyfriend Spencer that he's
going to be ok and that their
relationship will be ok - all while
scaling a mountain made of ice Gillan
completely steals the movie making good
on the promise she showed a decade ago
on Doctor Who Karen Gillan triumphs with
a positive winning performance despite
the way the script and filmmakers treat
the Ruby roundhouse character it's
understood that her character is
supposed to be an example of
unnecessarily provocative female
videogame characters Ruby engages yet
again in a lot of stunts and combat
dressed in a crop top and short shorts
but in Gillan on display why am I
wearing this outfit in a jungle tiny
little shorts and a leather halter top I
mean what is this showing off a little
skin is something to be expected from
major movies but it seems inappropriate
for Jumanji the next level a family film
in which the young female characters are
just as viable as warriors and
adventurers as the male characters
making things seem extra sleazy is how
Gillan is filmed there are plenty of
shots of her bare midriff and rear end
with next to no comparable exploited of
photography of muscle-bound co-starred
Dwayne Johnson there's a whole different
level of Jumanji the next level a gentle
satiation of videogame conventions and
jiae's the film is structured like a
video game arranged into different
worlds in areas including a desert the
jungle mountains and naturally at the
end a remote and punishing castle the
funniest video game sent up in the film
the one that makes viewers realize how
ridiculous and unrealistic video games
can be is the return of Nigel
Billingsley an NPC or non player
character that serves as a guide to the
characters comic actor Rhys Darby is
once again all in on his betrayal of the
soulless smiling helpful Nigel as he
moves the action along urging characters
to read instruction giving letters out
loud and congratulating the heroes on a
job well done and whinnies in the scene
but doesn't have a line Darby quietly
and perfectly stands on the periphery
doing and saying absolutely nothing just
like a real NPC Jumanji the next level
debuted in theaters in December 2019 the
end of the year is second only to summer
in terms of the big movie studios
rolling out their biggest flashiest
blockbusters and to get noticed in a
crowded marketplace
Jumanji film makers stacked their cast
with a number of major movie stars the
main cast consists of heavy hitters like
Dwayne Johnson Jack Black and Kevin Hart
and their adventure through video game
desert sand castles takes up the bulk of
the film's runtime other well-known
well-liked and bankable actors round out
the Jumanji the next level cast but
there just isn't enough for them to do
it's disappointing that the producers
hired such notable people if they were
barely going to use them the great Danny
DeVito and Danny Glover appear early in
the film Espenson grumpy grandfather
Eddie and estranged friend Milo
respectively then when their souls take
up residence in the bodies of videogame
avatars they disappear in favour of the
avatar actors doing impressions of
DeVito and Glover Nick Jonas and Colin
Hanks reprised their roles from Jumanji
welcome to the jungle but only show up
when the film is nearly over
additionally recognizable and reliable
sitcom stars John Ross Bowie and lamorne
Morris appear and explicably in tiny
parts delivering just a few lines each
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]